It's changed enormously.
Uh,
I'm in television was already the
dominant factor when I came in,
but uh,
in 1960,
but there was a real sort of balance
between print and television at that,
at that point,
under campaign buses,
the print reporters still sat up front
and the television people sat in the
back of the bus.
That changed pretty quickly.
And now of course with cable,
uh,
both,
networks and the print our in the back
seat and cable is driving the bus.
It's a problem that is a kind of a
artifact of the,
I think mostly the television,
a role as the dominant channel of
communication for politicians.
What the politicians learned was that if
they maintain the old fashioned way of
campaigning,
a set speeches,
complex tax on foreign policy or foreign
policy or economic policy,
that reporters had wide range as to what
they chose to report from those
speeches.
But if they framed their message each
day in a single sound byte,
particularly if they could do it in
front of a dramatic setting,
a closed steel mill or a polluted
stream,
that became the message for the
television coverage.
And so with television you went,
you had essentially was a shrinkage of
the daily message from the campaigns to
that sound byte level.